Hello Freak bitches.
So here,
here we have a natural disaster
happening in our own country.
You know,
barreling in,
nobody at burning man knows about it
because there's no cell phone service back
in 2007 it's barreling
in and a 2005 rather.
And we watch it coming in.
Now the,
the amazing thing was we sought,
you could watch a video for more bit on
this screen on this guy's screen and you
could watch people walking
down like we saw levy breach,
the first levy breach in like
the ninth ward or something.
We saw that on the screen from
plot from our camp at burning man.
So when you say you took over satellites,
satellites that are broadcasting,
what is it?
Broadcasting media like it was high Rez.
No Hi-Rez reconnaissance imagery.
Okay,
so it's a satellite that is like one
of those spying on bad guy satellites.
Exactly.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Eat,
we couldn't read.
You gotta talk about this Ad.
If someone finds out about that,
is that like is this an issue?
I don't think so.
I mean not like something that
would be really frowned upon.
Well,
the,
the phone,
the iridium phone kept ringing.
Yeah.
It's like your dad's calling,
you're having a party.
The neighbors are calling your dad going,
hey man,
uh,
I don't know what your son's doing,
but uh,
the lights are on,
there's a million people on your front
lawn and the phone just keeps ringing and
you're like,
ah,
but these guys knew who
they're dealing with.
This is this innovative genius type
guy that is totally respected and
organization.
So the general that initiated
the inquiry was covering for him.
Oh,
I see.
So the general could then
contact space command and say,
I can't get any information.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
So I see.
He had put the satellite in some
kind of a failsafe fallback mode.
So they would spend the next several
days trying to get back into it.
Whoa.
He was just like,
we kept passing it and keep me out,
burn hydrazine and locate,
you know,
stuff on the Playa.
Wow.
So how would,
tell me all the details,
but he's at basically,
don't you know,
I'm doing this,
nobody was interested in me.
What do you want to hear?
Songs about me being miserable.
Yeah.
I would have the day,
man.
I was a grand old time and,
uh,
reveling in,
in,
in everything I had,
you know,
I grew up wanting a playboy playmate,
I wanted,
I got all,
you know,
I got all that stuff.
It was,
and it was terrific.
The great thing about having things is
it gives you a chance to see whether you
really want it,
you know?
And that,
that's,
that's pretty cool.
People spend their lives,
um,
sometimes chasing things
that they never get.
I've been very fortunate.
I've pretty much gotten everything
I chased and some of it,
it was all worth having,
but it wasn't all worth keeping.
So what you thought it
would before you got there,
why did,
sometimes I thought that certain things
would be the solution and only white
playmate.
Yeah.
I mean,
it wasn't done for Thursday.
It was a solution.
Um,
but um,
you know,
look,
uh,
again,
my life's been awesome,
awesome.
And,
um,
it got me to here and,
uh,
you know,
when you hear poor me,
when you hear people talking,
poor me,
it's a lonely and you know,
it,
my life's been great.
Um,
and it's all led me to where I am now.
And,
uh,
I,
I have nothing but great
memories and no regrets.
So you don't have to go
to therapy at all anymore.
You don't do any of that.
I go,
I go sometimes once I,
if I can,
I go once a week,
once a week.
Yeah.
As I said to me,
it's not laying on a couch and,
and you know,
trying to,
trying to figure out a minutia.
It's really a great if,
if you have a great therapist,
it's great conversation.
Literally,
Hey,
here's what I did.
I did this this week and you know,
it's,
um,
I call it life school.
It's just kind of,
you know,
I don't expect somebody else
to be able to tell me what,
what the answer is.
They probably don't have
the answer for them.
You know when,
when we put therapists or doctors that
when we put anybody on a pedestal where
we're on dangerous ground,
these are just people,
they have their own issues.
They may be great at helping you,
but it doesn't mean that they
have the answer for them.
We're all,
we're all out there
trying to figure it out.
Them too.
I'm like,
no one's like,
diets aren't going to work.
Right,
right.
This has to be a lifestyle change,
right?
Like you can't like go for three
months eating salads and then be like,
Hey,
I got my weight down,
I got my cholesterol down and got my
diabetes down and then going back to it.
It's like you have to have,
but I'm like,
but I love food.
Like I love eating and so
the thing I'm doing now,
which I put,
didn't put too much research
into his chewing and spitting.
There's,
I know guys who did that with meat.
There's some MMA fighters like Diego
Sanchez was doing that for a while.
He wouldn't eat meat.
He would just chew it up.
It's horrible for you.
Is it really?
It's horrible for you
because first of all,
so you get like,
so I'll order like three entrees,
I'll get spaghetti fried chicken,
steak,
I'll get pie,
I'll order everything.
It's just like Roman
Times gluttony to the Max.
Right.
And I'll have like the worst is if it's
at a nice restaurant cause then they
don't have the,
they have like cloth Napkins and I'm like
can you bring some more of those paper
Napkins?
And I'm sitting there and I'm like,
and I'm just chewing everything,
getting all the flavor out of
it and then I'm spitting it,
which the mouth,
as soon as it starts
chewing and making saliva,
the stomach starts making acid to
prepare for the food co to come down.
But if the food never comes down,
there's just like acid in your stomach,
you know?
And,
and also when you eat,
all the sugar already goes into your
like before it hits your stomach,
you know?
Yeah.
So I'm eating all this food that like
nice restaurants and chewing it and
spitting it and Napkins and then,
and then putting it like on the
plate and the dude's comes sooner.
Is there,
is there something wrong with the meal?
I'm like,
no,
it's delicious.
It's fucking amazing.
And then you know,
you're looking for shortcuts,
bro.
I'm looking for shortcuts.
You can't do that.
Why don't you just hire a real trainer?
Not not critter,
but hire someone who's like a real legit
strength and conditioning trainer who's
gonna put you through some stuff.
If you really want to
do something that's fun,
you should or you're fired.
You should take a martial art.
Yeah,
I guess.
I mean you did judo.
I think I need a hot chick.
How would that work for the trainer?
Cause then I'll be motivated
and just Kinda wanna fuck her.
Well that's it.
If you can't fucker,
you want to bring other girls hotter
around to show her that you can pack them.
Like,
listen bitch,
I could fuck them.
Why can't I fuck you?
And then it will become
some weird ego thing.
And Joe having an eating disorder is
the number one thing that like bond with
hot chicks because they all have one.
I'm like,
should I go a anorexic or chewing and
spitting or bulemia and they're like,
well I tried but I'm like,
cool.
It's like all of a sudden like this
super boring dumb girl is like all like,
Oh yes,
but a lot of like crossfit chicks,
they don't have eating disorders.
If you get like a strength
and conditioning type cow,
you're right Joe.
I do have boatloads of money.
I got to figure out how not a shortcut.
I just need to figure out
to make not cure cancer,
not cure aids,
some kind of delicious food that
you can eat every day and you that.
It's why this is the thing.
The more you suffer,
the more you'll enjoy pleasure.
You are a glutton for pleasure,
my friend,
but you love.
But here,
check this out.
So my,
my Japanese business partner,
I work with this company.
Good smile.
It's not legal in America yet,
but he has,
he smokes,
he drinks,
he eats all this shit.
I don't even know what
this process is called.
You might have heard of it,
but he did once a month.
This is like real rich guy,
shit.
He gets all like a lot of his blood
taken out and then they do shit to it.
Like they make it into super blood and
then he puts it back into them and then
everything goes down.
His,
his,
you know,
and I go,
what is that?
It's not,
it's not FDA,
whatever tested.
It's not in America yet.
And so,
okay.